[Applause]
since Friday everyone what a crowd
love it I'm Pete hexath in for Greg
Gutfeld tonight Who's off doing God
knows what
anyway let's welcome tonight's guest his
Biden impression is so accurate he's
forgotten how to tie his own shoes Fox
News contributor Tom shallou
[Music]
she goes against the grain like
something someone with celiac disease
Deputy opinion editor at Newsweek Batya
Ungar Sargon
when he asks women for their numbers
they they only give the one for the
suicide hotline
actor writer and comedian Jamie lizzo
and her meltdowns brought a trademark
infringement suit from Chernobyl Fox
News contributor captain
all right it's Friday so before we get
to some news stories let's do this
Greg's leftovers
it's leftovers where I read the jokes we
did not use this week and just like Greg
does it this is my first time reading
these so here we go
Donald Trump has announced a contest
where the prize is a free dinner at his
New Jersey Golf Course sounds good
former Governor Chris Christie called it
grandstanding
then asked how many times you're allowed
to enter the contest
too easy Kim Kardashian has reached out
to Tom Brady about buying a vacation
home near his place in the Bahamas
in return Brady asked Kim if she needed
help deflating her ass
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I was at a leftover
s Jen's ears are upset at Howard Stern
after a compilation of his lewd comments
towards women went viral the comments
resurfaced when someone Googled the
phrase Howard's turn
it's about right
new and geological research warns that
the height of skyscrapers is causing
Manhattan to sink lower into the
surrounding bodies of water
while some scientists blame other causes
it's pretty good it's pretty good
Alec Baldwin became a grandfather for
the first time this week when his
daughter Ireland gave birth to a baby
girl
friends and loved ones are predicting
her first work words will be don't and
shoot
[Applause]
all right this week a 2.2 magnitude
earthquake Quake hit Yonkers New York
according to reports the Quake caused
thousands of dollars worth of
improvements
Tom lives in yoga is it true no
we'll get back to that
Christian Dior is paying Johnny Depp 20
million to remain as the face of its new
cologne
because if anyone knows the importance
of smelling good it's the guy who shared
a bed with Amber Heard
[Applause]
just the facts just the facts
Pilots for Southwest Airlines have voted
overwhelmingly to go on strike later
this year now the vote was supposed to
take place weeks ago but got stuck in
Phoenix
the USDA is Banning is weighing a ban on
chocolate milk for school lunches
they're concerned the added sugar makes
it harder to pay attention in
pornography class
oh
that's what it turns into yep
and finally scientists have discovered
in ancient text that showed the first
kissed in his kiss in history was
recorded nearly 5 000 years ago
I remember it well said the president
Bravo
to the writers of Gutfeld
all right now to some news so who will
crack the Moet Chandon a guy named Ron
or the dude named Don
did DeSantis eat an edible when he said
only three candidates are credible
DeSantis and Trump are turning up the
heat in the race for the White House
while Biden can't even find the starting
line
DeSantis reportedly told his donors all
six of them
on a phone call that there are basically
three people at this point in the race
who are credible in the election
Biden Trump and him
sorry RFK the Democrats don't hold real
primaries just ask Bernie
and of those three DeSantis thinks only
he and Biden actually have a chance
even though polls show Trump running
circles around him like the teacup ride
at the Magic Kingdom
so explain yourself Ron only three
credible candidates
including sleepy Joe who shakes hands
with magical people
come on man
what's that mean for Tim Scott he's not
credible Nikki Haley Mike Pence not
credible they may be one percenters as
Donald likes to say
but they're getting less interest than
Chris Christie's Peloton
thank you
but aren't they credible I mean if you
ask me it sounds like Ron's living up to
his disanctimonious nickname
kind of like I did when Al Qaeda
prisoners at Guantanamo Bay called me
Lieutenant Hegg waterboarding
then you got this whole Disney dust up
Disney just announced they are pulling 1
billion in investment from Florida
something the Trump Camp is hitting him
on saying quote Ron DeSantis is having a
no good very bad week letting Disney
steamroll him everything he's saying is
exactly what Consultants tell candidates
to manipulate and bamboozle them it sure
does feel like establishment Republican
candidates are running Ron's show
right into the ground the closer his
announcement get gets the lower his
numbers go
is it too late for Hillary to run
just a picture
is it too late for her to run for
governor of Florida she could at least
scare away the alligators too
so what's old Joe think of this Trump
DeSantis back and forth
no no no no don't let him fight it out
let them pound each other I don't care
that's good for me
besides that feel pretty good
did you see my poll numbers against
orange man bad I'm up
I'm high man
I am in this High since the time I
accidentally borrowed 100 straws put it
in my Ensure
I'll give you a kick
what not a joke
Joe Biden everybody
so buy you let me start with you what do
you what do you make of De Santa saying
there are only three credible candidates
I think the media is really thirsty for
this uh DeSantis Trump match-up they
really want to see something that hap
you know along the lines of Hillary
versus Bernie you know that the voters
are some somehow divided on this issue
and ready to fight but I really don't
see it that way I think that this santis
has a point even though he's very
sanctimonious I agree with you I think
the point he's trying to make is that
the Trump base is not going to go for a
Nikki Haley or a Tim Scott the Trump
base is the American working class that
has been sold out by the elites of both
sides what they are looking for is a
candidate who says to them the way
president Trump did in 2016 they stole
everything from you and I'm here to get
it back now the problem with Trump is
that he spends a lot of time these days
saying they stole everything from me and
I'm gonna get it back and I think that
that is the opening for DeSantis he can
learn from that from from Trump's
strengths but also his weaknesses so
maybe credible was the wrong word Jamie
does Santas have a chance in 2024.
I think he has a chance um but as I hear
him I used to like really be behind him
and I think he's been losing me recently
but man the lengths that this man will
go to not have to take his kids to
Disney World
[Laughter]
I heard he's flying a lawsuit against
Chuck E cheese and build a bear
[Laughter]
I think he's got a chance I think and I
think it's fun to watch but have you
been to Disney I haven't been to Disney
recently you guys it's uh it's a mad
house it's great I saw a lot of kids on
um leashes
have you seen that the kids and I I
think I don't think it's fair to the kid
I felt bad I think if you are a kid put
on a leash you should be able to get on
the ground that's just a thing
your voice
the parents clean up right behind me in
the back right yeah absolutely Tom is
the Disney strategy Disney strategy a
right one because DeSantis is leaning
into it hard yeah no I think it is I I
you know and I don't I look at what's
going on I know there's a lot of
headlines this week oh big laws for
DeSantis who did no Disney continues to
hurt their brand they're not a good
player on the national stage and
DeSantis knows it so I think he's
playing it exactly right the one who's
getting weakened by this battle is
Disney because people are unhappy with
them Trump now let's talk about I'll get
to DeSantis when he finally announces
when he gets in the race I'll be rough
on him but I'll tell you who had a bad
week Trump because he keeps trying to
run to the left of DeSantis I'm not
impressed okay when he when he comes out
in the side of Disney forget about it
and last week when he threw pro-life
people under the bus because he said
that the heartbeat bill was what was the
word he used he said it was uh it was
too harsh and he said it wasn't good for
women I'm not impressed when Trump tries
to run to the left because I'm right
wing and if you're Maga you hold Trump's
feet to the fire right don't let him
he's going to run against the Santas and
he's gonna have to win my vote you got
that Trump
watch this
okay now you told me in the Green Room
you wish we could have eight more years
of trump in addition to the four we've
already had
no I said I think Jeb Bush is going to
be the guy
but but hold on I mean it's been it's
been amazing because you got a book he
wins reelection by a massive amount in
Florida he's got a successful book tour
huge media coverage lots of money and
Trump gets rated uh prosecuted and a CNN
Town Hall where they were supposed to
get him and he got them and his numbers
go up I mean it's a very interesting
Dynamic well you know who else had a lot
of money Jeb Bush like he was supposed
to be the guy a lot of us are sitting
around oh yeah Jeb Bush is the guy and
like people only remember him he
probably can like go around in public
without anybody be like what's your name
um I think what Trump did here was
really interesting because he
attacked DeSantis on policy right
instead of HE generally tends to attack
people more on personality like low
energy Jeb for example
um and with how what DeSantis is doing
which I haven't liked what he's done for
Disney even though I I don't like Disney
I just don't like the government to be
involved in business in that way
um as far as their tax status I don't
even believe in taxes at all so I'm my
opinion my opinions are relevant on that
but um you know he he said hey this is
bad for business and I'm the business
guy which is what people liked about him
kind of all along now he did title the
whole thing president Trump is always
right so he hasn't really he's not like
more C-SPAN friendly than before but I
think that attacking on policy I think
that's probably a better strategy for
Trump well I'm sure he'll take your
advice oh yeah oh yeah prone to doing
that yeah he always does all right good
discussion folks hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not not get it anywhere else